value added tax VAT hello my name is too
cute I design rocket-propelled clothes I
came to earth because I am fascinated by
your shoes there is no such thing on my
planet I have a great idea I will design
rocket-propelled shoes Europeans love
shoes I will make my shoes in the
European Union but if I set up a
business I think I have to pay VAT I
[Music]
want to know more about VAT
Wow the restaurant has gone through many
changes as a result of the high demand
they invested in their staff and in
their kitchen the restaurant added value
to the original supplies so they can
sell the meal for more than it costs
them to make it they can add more value
if the food is fancier the restaurant is
more attractive and if the waiters are
more attentive so that's why the food
looks so good a factory of electronic
components purchases material from a
provider the provider charges the
factory one euro plus VAT of 10 Euro
cents after that he pays the 10% VAT to
the state budget the factory of
electronic components adds value through
its manufacturing process of creating
the components that it sells to a
smartwatch manufacturing company for 2
euro plus VAT of 20 Euro cents half of
the VAT is paid by the factory to the
state budget and the other half goes
back to the factory for the previously
paid VAT the smartwatch manufacturing
company produces smartwatches with the
components bought and after that sells
to a retailer for 3 euro plus VAT a 30
euro cents 10 euro cents of this VAT go
to the state budget and the other 20
Euro cents go back to the SmartWatch
company for the previously paid fat the
retailer makes a sale to a customer for
5 euro plus VAT of 50 euro cents 20 euro
cents of this fat go to the state budget
for every item board the consumer pays
VAT and the buyers earlier in the chain
of production
receive reimbursements for previous VAT
taxes paid
so what is the e use role in collecting
taxes the EU does not have a direct role
in collecting taxes or establishing tax
rates the amount of tax you pay is set
and collected by the Member States nor
to European level but what is the EU
contribution the role of the European
Union is to ensure that taxes are fair
and helpful to everyone they do this by
promoting growth and job creation
ensuring the free movement of goods
services and capital across the EU
single market ensuring that businesses
in a country to not have an unfair
advantage over competitors in another
country combating discrimination against
consumers workers or businesses in other
EU countries in the single European
market goods and services can be freely
marketed outside national borders
therefore minimum rates for that and
excise duties have been set and rules
have been laid down for their
application if they wish
governments are free to apply higher
rates what about the EU budget the EU
budget is mainly funded ninety nine
percent from its own resources annual
revenue must cover or annual expenditure
a source of revenue for the EU budget is
that meaning that a percentage of that
collected by the countries is
transferred to the European Union how is
this EU budget administrated less
economically developed countries receive
higher amounts from the EU budget than
they contribute and this will continue
throughout the next budget period 2014
through 2020 so much useful information
about that do you understand the concept
of added value did you identify the VAT
rate in your country